well first of all congrats on this show
listen this just feels like the most
natural fit for somebody like yourself
was this always a dream of yours growing
up this was my dream since childhood to
have my own daytime talk show I used to
run home and tape over my mother's soap
operas with daytime talk shows I would
get in a lot of trouble but I did it
because watching daytime TV made me feel
not alone made me feel like the things I
was going through
um you know other people were going
through and now being adult and and
being able to have people on my show
that are being vulnerable and being
willing to talk about their their
challenges so that I could help them you
know um I think it's great you know we
forgot that like you know people talk
about their challenges on TV doesn't
have to be salacious that's one of the
things that I've learned from from queer
eye is that people want to see
themselves reflected in other people
they want to see their journey and their
challenges but it doesn't have to be
crazy and so for me it's like how can we
get it back to a place where daytime TV
is you know what it what it used to be
in the early early days with the
Philadelphia's you know and so I'm
excited to bring conflict TV back to the
masses I saw that Kelly Clarkson who is
the queen of daytime TV gave you the
most warm welcome what did it feel like
to have Kelly throw her support behind
yourself I am a Kelly Stan
um not fan Stan and it's because I think
she and I both came from reality
television we both started our Journeys
with showing the world just who we were
and you know what we were about and she
showed her Talent of a singer I kind of
came out and was like this is this is me
you've never seen this personality but I
want to be here to help people and for
us to Now guide ourselves to this place
and for her to have the Epic career she
has you know she's an international
Superstar I'm like
oh my gosh so it was pretty pretty
amazing I mean it feels it feels good to
be embraced by those who I respect
um and who are my peers
um and so it's it makes me feel
emotional
yeah listen there were so many great
daytime talk shows growing up like
Montel Williams comes to mind Sally
comes to mind Ricky Lake there were a
lot when we were growing up is there a
talk show that you were most invested in
yourself as a kid well I'm Phil Donahue
that was the one that I was obsessed
with
um and Phil actually
um on my journey Hold On by to find it
for you really quickly
um oh I'm sorry he actually sent a
message to me
um congratulating me and I you know
wishing me the best and sort of flossing
on his all of his Emmys and um it's
probably one of the most amazing things
ever but it just filled on you so I'm
trying to find this really quickly it's
oh here it goes right here
this is before it started look at this
[Music]
and by the way I'd know a little about
that this is my mean wall hey all those
Emmys I mean I just thought it was
amazing for the man that I watched
growing up that I respect so much and
who really stays on my heart when I'm
talking to guests you know for me like
when I'm talking to someone like as
they're telling me their challenges it's
also about like how can we solve this
how can we better be better what's the
resources and and also
how can you know the world start having
a conversation that maybe they weren't
having before how would you say uh
Karama your time being part of the
iconic series queer eye kind of prepped
you for a role like this
um in a lot of ways because on queera I
was able to meet all different walks of
life and learn actually learn how to
solve people's problems quickly because
on queer eye you know I might have you
know my own even though I'm with them
for five days or four and a half days
you know when I get to really get in and
go deep is for like maybe two hours an
hour and a half and so it taught me how
to like really be an empathetic listener
to really like get to the core of the
problem
um it also taught me how to have a lot
of fun because you know when you're
working with you know Jonathan tan Bobby
and Anthony the five of us together are
just so silly and so for me on my show
it's nice to not only be able to help
people to say Hey listen after the
challenges we can all have a little fun
do a little twerk you know do something
that this is going to bring joy to us
yeah definitely which of the five uh
which of the four of them had the best
reaction to the news about you getting
this show
um it would either be Bobby or tan
um they tan and Bobby are they all had a
great reaction by the way but I think
Bobby and tan had probably the biggest
reactions Tang got emotional for me
because he knew it was my dream I've
been saying it since the first day
um Bobby was just screaming and you know
like crazy and I think that was also the
first two I told
um and so
um it was great but Jonathan was so
supportive and so was Anthony it's super
important when you have a space like
this in daytime television to cover
topics that are incredibly important and
impactful to people across the world how
are you navigating which topics you want
to discuss on the show
um for me it's it's right now we're
growing we're only in week three or four
and so it's about like making sure that
the things that are going are hurting
people's self-esteem the things that are
hurting people's mental health like
whether it be relationships with their
partners with that they don't navigate
that you know cheating communication
um lying also navigating relationship
with partner I mean parents and with you
know siblings I've done a lot of that as
well because for me it's that family
Dynamic you know we're getting close to
the holidays and I'm tired of the
holidays being a time when people come
and argue and like can't enjoy it you
know for me it's about like let's come
do the work before the holidays on the
caramel show and then you have a good
time with your holidays you know what I
mean no argument yeah but also I'm I'm
reaching out past that to see like you
know things like we did an amazing
episode on body positivity and we're
going to be doing more body positivity
is something that needs to be talked
about because for some reason in our
social media age people feel entitled to
talk about other people's body we're
seeing it right now but like how people
bring up a lizzo and it's like that
woman is a talented gorgeous human being
that I disrespect so much and I think to
myself have I ever seen in the media of
people or on social media people talk
about you know you know some of the men
that Joe Biggie Smalls I never heard
anyone talk about their weight in the
way that we're talking about lizelle's
weight and I have I have current people
I use people that were you know from the
different generation not to get myself
in trouble but you know we never we
don't talk about men that way and so
like for me it's about shutting down
those type of conversations on my show
and teaching the world like men don't
have a right to comment on women's
bodies
um and that we should be supporting
people on their Journey as they're
loving themselves right where they are
love that so much because for a long
time daytime television was very
salacious you know what I mean even when
it came to queer stories on daytime
television they were always uh very
salacious and not on my show not on my
show
that's what I love I love that we're
bringing these the humanity back to the
stories especially queer stories because
it's so important because for a long
time it was just salacious oh my gosh
it's a drag queen oh my gosh they're
trans oh my gosh two guys dating but I
love that you're not doing that and
you're bringing the humanity of the
queer Community back to daytime
television I appreciate you saying that
and I have to tell you it's important
for me it is something that I personally
believe is part of the mission of me
having this show is to make sure that
people understand that members of the
queer Community are just like the rest
of us we are human beings who deserve
love and respect and we are going to
settle for no less and so when we talk
about someone's trans experience when we
talk about someone who is in a same-sex
relationship it's always going to be
talked about with sec I mean with um
with respect but not not trying to
sugarcoat because the thing is I tell
people all the time the same arguments
you're having in your home with your
partner me and my boyfriend have and so
you know it's we actually can relate to
each other and learn from each other
more one where it's not salacious and
the same thing to be honest with you
with
um you know African-Americans and
Latinos usually on those shows they are
shown a certain way and for me you know
one of the things that I've noticed is
that
I've been able to disarm individuals who
come out thinking like they have to be a
certain way and I say immediately that
no no no no no it doesn't matter your
economic status you still deserve
respect and you still deserve to be
heard and you still deserve to receive
tools you know there's an uh an episode
where I was talking to two
African-American women about
generational trauma and these women were
mother-daughter fighting and yet I got
them to go to therapy on my show I asked
them to go to therapy and the hesitation
from the women was real because they
were like we don't know if we believe in
this and so for me lgbtqia stories
stories of people of color it's
important for me to do those stories
right
uh last question there are a lot of
stories that are within Hollywood that I
think would work so well on your show
you I think of people like even uh Kanye
West and Kim Kardashian right now those
two seem to be having a lot of issues
that I would love to bring them on you
got to connect listen we can talk about
Kanye West's mental health we can talk
about where he's at we can talk about
how that's affecting him and his wife
his ex-wife we could talk about how it's
going to be affecting those kids listen
Kanye Kim invitation come on the caramo
show I will support you a hundred
percent with that that was going to be
my final question dream guest who would
you love to sit down and work something
out with
I haven't thought about that you are the
first person to ask me that to be honest
with you
um because we're just now getting into
the place of having celebrities because
they're reaching out to the show now
because they know me from queer eye and
they're saying hey I trust caramel I
actually want to talk to him about my
relationship issues
um that I haven't thought about the
dream guess yet you are good
um let me think who would that be you
want to know who I think would be a
great fit right now that just came to my
mind somebody like Jeanette McCurdy who
released the book recently about her
mother's death I'm glad my mother died I
feel like that oh my God more important
conversation that you would be fantastic
at so my question
um after you're doing et Canada can you
also just come over and co-host coromo
show with me because that was a
phenomenal idea and I think two minds
are better than one so baby I am there
anytime any day listen come on down come
on down and if not co-hosting I want to
come to a set visit sit on that set and
talk face to face with you yes I would
love that please I would really love
that we'll make that happen listen if
when that interview happens I'm going to
literally personally send you a bottle
of champagne and say thank you I'm not
joking you are the sweetest thank you so
much I'm gonna make that happen that's
gonna happen soon okay yes of course
congrats on everything thank you
everyone thank you